this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
pregnancy is the time period during
which a baby develops inside your uterus
it usually lasts about 40 weeks starting
from the first day of your last
menstrual period
these 40 weeks are grouped into three
segments called trimesters
the first trimester lasts about 13 weeks
during the first two weeks you aren't
actually pregnant because of the way
your due date is calculated
but your body is preparing for pregnancy
during the second week an egg is
released from your ovary in a process
called ovulation
around the end of the second week the
baby is conceived in a process called
conception or fertilization
this happens when a sperm from the
father merges with the egg from the
mother usually in the fallopian tubes
during conception genetic material from
the mother and father combine to form a
unique genetic code instantly
determining sex hair color eye color and
hundreds of other characteristics
this new single cell called a zygote or
embryo is the beginning of a new human
being
during the third week the zygote divides
to form a hollow ball of cells called a
blastocyst
the cells of the blastocyst begin to
arrange themselves into two groups
the inner group will develop into your
baby and the outer group will form
tissues to nourish and protect it
during week four the blastocyst moves
into the uterus
where it hatches out of its outer layer
once freed from this outer layer the
blastocyst can embed itself in the
thickened lining of the wall of the
uterus in a process called implantation
weeks five to ten are referred to as the
embryonic period
all of the major organs start to grow
such as the brain
spinal cord and heart
the heart begins to beat during this
period
[Music]
structures called the placenta and
umbilical cord begin providing life
support for the embryo
they bring nutrients and oxygen from the
mother to the embryo
bones and muscles start to grow beneath
thin transparent skin
toward the end of the embryonic period
the embryo starts to look more human
at the end of week 10 the embryo is now
called a fetus and is about one and a
quarter inches long from head to rump
during the next few weeks the arms and
legs grow longer and start to move
fingers and toes finish developing
and the baby's face becomes well formed
by the end of the first trimester your
baby is almost three inches long
your body experiences many changes
during the first trimester this is due
to changing levels of chemicals called
hormones circulating through your body
the most common first sign of pregnancy
is that your menstrual periods have
stopped
you may have other symptoms as well such
as nausea often called morning sickness
that can occur at any time of day
tender swollen breasts
mood swings
constipation
weight loss or weight gain
craving or disliking certain foods
and feeling more tired than usual
you may have only a few of these
symptoms or none at all
if you have any questions about how your
baby is developing or concerns about how
you're feeling talk to your health care
provider